absolutely boy in China and I came to
New York to go to college I have to go
music when I was I think 17 years old so
to the question how I discovered my
piano and I was born from music family
the father he survived very very
talented violinist and the mom was a
very famous dancer in China before so I
have this I was lucky enough to have the
background that I was always surrounded
by music my dad got me a piano be first
born but then I started by then first
when I was three years old to study with
him and later for some reason next which
the piano and I just fell in love with
the sound I guess and then I began my
journey when I was asked or member I
wrap every chance to have to go to
master classes to listen to different
concerts to try to get this little bit
of the culture but still it's not enough
you're living in China two different
world you know that's probably why when
I was very young I've said it I made my
I have this very firm determination the
decision that I was come to New York one
day to continue studying piano I'll say
oh it happened so fast just like how
China is developing in the night 15 20
years almost before maybe 25 years ago I
don't think anyone actually placed piano
there well few people but now that's
commonly like right now and then things
start to change so fast
China was trying to keep up with the
world I guess the industrial world
developing too fast and they're always
trying to give August elections whatever
fresh America
whatever America has was not whatever
American people are doing so well then I
guess it's a symbol Western symbol that
piano is something so ideal for them
you're dreaming maybe it's a part of
freedom they're looking for a consumer
sell that soldier we do have a mission
to to push it forward
I doesn't matter how how the world it's
gonna be it's gonna how the world will
become but I think it'd be kind of up if
we try very large to protect this last
bit of the culture the piano the great
culture I think we can make it so I
don't care I will just practice plan I'm
using I love it and wherever a girl
white hole people will always enjoy
music and I would like to share it it's
never been corner of the world